in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Andy
and Alicia are with us ours it is it
Alysha its Alisa
Alicia okay welcome guys how are you
doing well better than we deserve sir
whoo where do you guys live well we're a
Navy family on our way to our next duty
station from Jacksonville Florida mm-hmm
Everett Washington very cool well thank
you for your service thanks appreciate
it very much
and so you're here to do a debt free
scream yes sir I love it you made it we
made it good for you how much have you
paid off $65,000 awesomeness I love it
and how long did that take 16 months
well done and your household income
during that time a hundred and seventeen
excellent excellent
so Andy what are you doing the Navy I'm
a Surface Warfare Officer say again I'm
a Surface Warfare Officer a Surface
Warfare Officer sir okay I know no more
than before I asked all right good do
you work outside the home no I stay home
with these three with these three kiddos
okay what are their names and ages this
is well he's 12 mm-hmm this is Drew he's
11 mm-hmm this is Sarah she's nine all
right yeah you got the team here you're
ready to go they're my team good stuff
good stuff all right so what kind of
debt was the 65,000 advance pay from a
move that we made from Germany bought a
new car with the advance pay and we had
a credit card that wouldn't go away okay
so you get advanced pay but you have to
pay it back that's not be a zero
interest loan but they don't just take
it out of your shoe and you can schedule
it to come out over 12 months or 24
months and we opted for the more
aggressive but it really put a hurt on
us yeah okay so the 12-month plan on
that I'm guessing since you did this in
16 yes and then the rest of it you had
to get after so how much of it was
advanced pay 15,000 okay and then how
much was the other stuff there's a
credit card that you know ranged from 15
to 17 mm-hmm and a $43,000 car you said
we could keep it then
and what is it hi Audi q5 okay no a nice
car very nice
all right so cool so what happened 16
months ago that flipped the switch and
caused all this to occur we had $76 for
groceries whoa and they eat a lot yeah
he didn't understand why that's the only
thing we had in the bank account when he
felt like he made money and he worked
his life was making a hundred grand and
he has 76 bucks and he didn't understand
so you were handling the money by
yourself yeah Fleming
oh he handled it right you're handling
him by yourself and he didn't he didn't
really know what was going on not really
okay now and and so you you get ready to
go do something or 76 bucks and that
discussion must have not gone well not
so well no sir
I'd say when we got married 14 years ago
good friend of ours gave us your your
book and she read it and I read excerpts
and put it on the shelf mm-hmm so we
came up to $76 and said okay let's go
see Uncle Dave okay so what we're doing
here go simple did you want a glass then
or we did we a versa
yes sir okay cool military or just
regular just regular okay all right good
we finally had enough time together
where he could actually attend all nine
weeks uh-huh which is not normal in our
life yeah and God I know did that
exactly the right time yeah yeah just
when it was desperately needed
desperately yeah and so what has changed
after 14 years of marriage now in the
way you all do money he has a buy-in and
he and I talk about money more mm-hmm
rather than him just let me handle it
and then wonder what happened so now at
least we talked things through and he's
got visibility into the numbers yep yeah
looking at the budget with you and then
you go do the work yeah but you got the
work but not all the responsibility by
yourself yeah it's got to be feel better
for you yeah totally yeah yeah it's good
for both of us yeah we see it with
military families all the time that you
know
the military member is traveling a lot
doing business and so to speak and the
spouse that's left at home is carrying
all the weight of a lot of different
things in the family but money is one of
them and it's not that hard especially
with technologies we've got today for
the military member to be able to look
with their spouse and give them you know
everybody's carrying the decision making
together the weight of the household
together that way and then the other
stuff so that's exactly what you're all
did very good I'm proud of you yeah we
eduation we really love every dollar by
the way how bad is amazing and about two
weeks into his last ship tour he was
told that his ship was going to be going
into modernization and that we would be
separate for about ten ten months I
guess here and there he he went to Japan
for a couple months went to DC well we
stayed in Jacksonville finished out our
school year and now we're all coming
back together right now okay
and so just us being on the same page
has saved our lives yeah yeah it's
amazing yeah every dollar especially
with the every dollar plus with the app
and all you you really can use that when
you're overseas and stuff it's perfect
they stay right together and then you're
not having to carry all that by yourself
that's amazing very cool
so when people hear you got out of that
what do you tell them the secret is
follow every step we'd tried to
short-circuit it and do one step or
another and or just try and get out of
debt and we've been debt-free in the
past but we didn't do it wholeheartedly
we didn't follow the plan so for us it
was important to follow the plan and
stick to it good at following orders
well especially when they make sense and
they're proven yeah that's good that's
very cool I've got two things like okay
I think you need to get rid of credit
cards that's like when we took that for
you the first night I told him I said I
know you've bought into this when you
cut that credit card up and you closed
it
oh and he cut it up halfway through Wow
get it cool
that's when you know yeah you're right
the other thing was budget the budget is
so key with envelopes yeah and it with
all of them with every dollar the
combination that's a one-two punch right
there okay that's very good well
congratulations you guys I'm very proud
of you how's it feel amazing and you
know what else it's like god I used to
want to go and be a go-to ministry
minister in other countries and stuff
and God finally tapped me on the
shoulder he brought some people in my
life and said hey you're already in your
ministry you just don't know it you know
these young Navy families need you hey
ma'am and so I we have led to FPU
military Wow thank you uh-huh they were
wonderful our our church helped me with
the second one at Fort Caroline Baptist
in Jacksonville Florida yeah it's a
great ministry for a church in their
bases yeah and installations to offer
that and sometimes even pay for it for
the families because a lot of families
especially entry-level you know they
need the help
yes and it was wonderful to watch it
work and especially young people about
all the families really keep them from
getting 14 years down into it yeah you
could smack them silly kids you love it
you guys were fun your heroes thank you
so much thank you for your service and
thank you for your story absolutely
incredible very very well done so I've
well drew and Sarah been practicing a
debt-free screen oh yeah oh yeah this is
gonna be like epic yes it's not gonna be
like a wimpy debt-free screen this
turbulent full-on Navy debt-free
screaming yeah okay good I like it good
all right Andy and Alicia will Drew and
Sarah ah $65,000 paid off in 16 months
making 117 a year count it down let's
hear a debt free scream
that's how you doing right there baby
now we're gonna give you a copy of Chris
Hogan's retire inspired book because
that's the next step for you you're
gonna go from debt free now into wealth
and he's gonna take you and lead you
right through that we got a signed copy
for you thank you guys for coming by and
we want to be sure that that you you
know the next part of your journey we're
walking with you as well and thank you
for teaching those young folks in those
classes that's just huge it's just
amazing very good stuff man that's good
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show and so
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind